hi my name is sal khan i'm the founder
and faculty of the khan academy and
we're trying to educate the world
welcome to the presentation on basic
edition but in august of 1789 they've
already done their version of the
declaration of independence and the
process is called photosynthesis
i was tutoring my my cousins literally
and uh
i i had to kind of figure out a way to
scale myself up so i started recording
youtube videos and i started making
little software modules for them but i
made it so anyone could use them and
start getting a lot of traction what
saul khan has done is amazing he's taken
all this material
and broken them down into little
12-minute lectures i use it myself to
remind myself of things i have children
who like it so i was super happy he came
up and we got to talk about where does
he go now how can
my foundation helped him pursue this
dream and connect it up with the other
great things going on on the internet
i want to be a stand-alone virtual
school where anyone in the world wants
to learn anything
can go there start from the basics
progress as far as they need to go get
feedback get assessment get practice
and eventually i wanted to actually
become the operating system for what
goes on in the classroom where every
student's allowed to work at their own
pace and the teacher actually becomes
more of a mentor or a
of a coach
so i see saul khan as a pioneer in an
overall movement to
use technology to let more and more
people learn things know where they
stand
it's the start of a revolution
all the videos are all free
openly accessible at
www.khanacademy.org i think it's a huge
contribution
everybody should check it out